I'm dark just the I'm doctor I can't
walk at all hey everybody its charlie
now that we've had a chance to see
infinity war a billion times everyone
started to point out the continuity
errors so I wanted to make a video for
my top twenty there's a new round of
that spider-man ps4 giveaway going on
all you have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video first big one is actually right at
the beginning of the movie so the first
time we see Tony Stark he's walking with
Pepper Potts into the park discussing
their wedding Tony has his hoodie on
around his shoulders the sleeves are
tied in a knot covering the miniature
arc reactor on his chest during their
talk Pepper unties the knot and they
start to talk about it right after that
they cut to a three-quarter shot
close-up on Tony the hoodie disappears
and is nowhere to be seen for the
remainder of the scene it's tied up
around his waist we only see it again
when they go back to the sanctum with
dr. strange when they're in the sanctum
and Tony's deciding whether or not he
wants to call Steve Rogers time to
explain all the beef that they have
since civil war he whips out the flip
phone and in the screen you can see
reflection of the green screen that they
used to shoot all those scenes inside
the sanctum when they go out to fight
the black order in Tony activates his
mark 50 armor by pressing on his arc
reactor he starts to take off his shades
with his right hand
they disappear into his gauntlet because
their nanotech but then in the wide shot
right after that you still see the
sunglasses fully formed in his hand
close to his face when the mine stone is
still in visions forehead before Thanos
removes it when you see it sitting there
it's much much larger physically than
when Ultron first created him and put it
in his forehead throughout the course of
age of Ultron so age of Ultron mine
stone and visions for head is much
smaller than mine stone in visions for
head during infinity war when Thanos
uses the time stone to turn back time
after Scarlet Witch has destroyed the
mine stone vision Scarlet Witch is
screaming at the top of her lungs trying
to stop him in the next shot you seethe
anos hitting Scarlet Witch with his
right hand and you see him holding
vision by his neck with his left then in
the next shot you see tannaz reaching
for vision and grabbing his neck
to that I think is because they started
to work on the CG for that early early
on and they shot a bunch of different
versions of that scene
so the mish-mosh of footage that they
wanted to use later on just didn't quite
match up there's one point where Tony
calls Peter a millennial Peter's about
16 or 17 years old that firmly makes him
generation Z surprisingly Millennials
quite a bit older than that now but
after Anna's is victorious people
throughout the universe start
disintegrating with their remains
blowing away in the dust turning to
ashes this includes all their clothing
anything else they were wearing however
random inanimate objects survived
particularly Nick Fury's communication
device that souped up space pager that
he uses to call Captain Marvel so it's
one of those Bucky's armed arguments why
does Bucky's arm disappear because it's
a completely inanimate object but the
pager that Nick Fury was holding does
not the close-up on that screen was the
whole reason for this post-credit scene
to exist though it was a Captain Marvel
scene to let you know that she was
coming when Doctor Strange is still
fighting a beanie ma he strangles dr.
strange and he falls down his this cop
car next to him in the next scene when
Evan e-ma lifts the ground around
strange the cop car is nowhere to be
found
just completely disappears this is
another one of those CG problems where
you have a bunch of different teams all
over the place working on the same scene
so one team is working on one version of
the scene while the other team that's
actually shooting the actors is doing
something a little bit different when
Thor's on the guardianship explaining
Stormbreaker how it's going to help him
kill Thanos he actually pronounces
nineveh Lear wrong a couple times the
first two times he incorrectly calls it
Nevada Lear the third time he correctly
pronounces it need to volleyer so it's
just a small distinction but you can
understand how they tried so many
different takes of all these scenes
improvising a lot of moments pretty
understandable he says at 50 times he
gets it wrong a couple of those times
the reason why stuff like that makes it
into the film is is because his physical
performance may have been the best of
all the takes even though he was
pronouncing it slightly wrong in the way
he said it is so quickly that you really
have to pay attention to notice while
they're on evany Maas spaceship Tony
Peter and dr. strange escape have this
conversation
and for the entire scene Peters hair is
slicked back during his conversation
with Tony Peter says you can't be a
friendly neighborhood spider-man if
there's no neighborhood the camera cuts
to a speechless Tony then comes back to
Peter who now has a completely different
hairstyle featuring a bunch of Fringe
then when it cuts away and cuts back to
Peter his hair is a little bit different
again for the rest of the time on the
ship more hair problems Tony Stark's
mustache changes a couple times when
they're fighting on Titan when he tells
Thanos you throw another moon at me I'm
gonna lose it
his mustache is really dark and defined
then after Theo reveals that he knows
who Tony Stark's is surprising him you
see Tony in the very next shot his
mustache has way more gray the colors a
little bit different it's thicker it's
unkempt the eyeball seen when rocket
gives Thor the eyeball and the two are
discussing it Rockets standing next to
Thor in one shot but then in the next
shot later he appears in the pilot seat
fully seat belted even though the scene
is meant to be continuous
another CG goof when Groot is making the
handle for Stormbreaker it's shown
falling down on the ground with the
sharp side on the right in the hammer
side on the left when Thor starts to
activate it and it starts lifting off
the ground crackling with lightning the
sides are reversed bit of a story
continuity error between movies gamora's
backstory was very very different during
infinity war than what we originally
learned about her during that very first
guardians of the galaxy movie
so during guardians Jon see Riley's
character says that Gamora is the last
member of her species known to exist but
then during infinity war is this much
more complex story about danos erasing
half of all life than seeing that spark
and Gamora that inspired him to take her
with him knowing that someday he might
be able to use her to get the soul stone
a lot of people notice the Infinity
Gauntlet continuity error now that we've
known that the fake one was in Odin's
vault this whole time during Ragnarok so
if Odin gauntlet was fake and hella was
aware of that centuries ago before she
was imprisoned by Odin then why didn't
eat read mention it during the story he
told about how Thanos forced him to
create something that would allow him to
wield the power of all six stones at the
same time but it's just one of those
moments where you find that you know if
Eitri was creating Thanos as gauntlet
for the first time like this magical
device that no one had ever thought to
use before
then how did Oh Dean have one that it
existed in his vault for centuries
so Thanos's plan also changed quite a
bit between the first Avengers film what
they at least told us what his plan was
in infinity war during the post-credits
scene from that first Avengers film
Thanos's advisor says that the humans
cannot be ruled implying that that's
what Thanos original plan was just a
rule planet Earth from Titan while also
collecting the Infinity stones but then
obviously during infinity war all he
cares about are the Infinity stones the
only reason why he thinks to go to earth
is because two of them are there he
doesn't care about anything else that's
happening on that planet and during the
age of Ultron post-credit scene this is
a funny one he says fine I'll do it
myself
now remember the continuity is a little
bit different between films even though
within the release schedule of all the
MCU movies this was happening a couple
years ago this moment is happening right
before he goes to the Nova Corps to take
the Power Stone so this is also
happening a little bit before Thor
Ragnarok when Loki is still pretending
to be Odin so he says fine I'll do it
myself then promptly sends half of the
Black Order to go get two of the stones
for him and bring them back the only
other noticeable continuity error is
during the big Wakanda bite scene
there's as close up of Black Panther
when he gives the order to open the
shield there's a clearly visible scene
of the spandex suit that he runs around
in onset before they tune it up in
post-production to make it look like the
full-blown vibranium black panther
costume but let me know in the comments
if you spotted any other continuity
errors or story problems in the movie or
anything that you saw after watching it
a billion more times but congratulations
to the latest giveaway winner from my
last big video Nek Mason please email me
on the back end of my channel so I can
get your contact details but click here
for that new Thor Loki Thanos deleted
scene and click here for brand-new
Avengers for thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]